so there's a guy named Hans Neiman yep
and uh he beat Magnus Carlsen recently
yeah has been already what is was it
August September 4th oh it was September
so he beat him twice right recently once
is the allegations
the by the internet that Hans Neiman
cheated and then the second time
uh Magnus played a few moves and
forfeited and resigned there's actually
so there's three okay sorry no no yeah
can we go through this yes yes yes so
they play a live Esports event in Miami
Beach yes Eden Rock that's where I
actually interviewed Magnus yeah that's
where that was
Oh by weird circumstance I found myself
in Miami unrelated to chess event
and uh yeah it was a very dramatic event
for me for various reasons one of which
the camera stopped working halfway
through the conversation so I thought
yeah I saw that I also a side note I
really respect how you write comments
pin them at the top you add time stamps
you're like very true professional I'm
the complete opposite on YouTube when
I'm off the camera so I dig in the mud
from when I started on YouTube in 2020
I in June like May June 2020 I had no
subscribers so I got to a million in a
year I had a lot of people analyzing my
every move all of my small flaws and I I
love getting hate comments
because you pin you pin is it the
comment of Shame that's what it was it's
been named over the years by by folks I
never called it that but yeah it's it's
pin of Shame and it's a shame yes it's
been tough because now people pretend to
write hate comments just to get
attention so like anything the public
ruin the good thing
but it started that way it started with
people just shredding me to bits calling
me spin-offs of this and that and um
I think I'm I'm a human more than I am a
Creator an influencer an attention
seeker like I'm just a person so to me
even at the size of 1.6 million
subscribers now September 2022 I don't
understand that I've gotten big and that
I shouldn't do this stuff and that I
should be Beyond it or I shouldn't be
checking my social media as much as I do
and interacting one-on-one I'm still
very much a human being and my guilty
pleasure my way of killing time if I'm
not laying on the couch and playing some
jazz Blitz Games off stream is I just
interact with people who say nice things
and who say horrible things and I really
like to get into the head of the people
who say the terrible things now
sometimes you can sometimes they are
truly Trolls but sometimes people just
they just
just really hate you what's the
successful what's a successful
interaction with the person that's uh
trolling you what's up like at the end
of that Hero Journey that you were uh
yeah uh partaking in what's what's
like what's the top of the mountain look
like is the troll conquered and broken
mentally not no not mental I don't want
to I don't want to defeat I I honestly
sometimes somebody writes a very long
comment I'll just I'll respond with a
question mark
yeah oh so you're you're you see each
other like like a brother and sister
you're gonna travel together on this
journey of deep meaning like
introspection what does this mean yeah
I've had people write
I can't quote now but something about my
Persona my behavior this and that and I
just like respond to them and I say hey
it sounds crazy that a large Creator
might do something like this but this
kind of goes back to you you speak to
folks on a very respectful way if you
make a mistake you completely own up to
it so I have this sometimes these
one-on-one interactions where I say I
think you're reading too much into this
I think you're kind of you don't
understand maybe some of my humor or
sarcasm as such so you form this opinion
that I'm this kind of a person this and
that and now you're sort of anything I
do you're trying to attach to that
reasoning and here you are writing this
lengthy essay of why nobody should watch
my content and sometimes people go you
know what I think you have a point maybe
I should relax a little bit yeah I would
love I would love to sort of interview
and understand
the lives of the the folks that post
that kind of stuff I mean they're
they're human beings they have
interesting Journeys also I think they
often don't realize
I think they don't realize their comment
will be read by anybody especially you
maybe they think like they also don't
realize you're a human being I feel like
that's yeah and it's it's so interesting
to watch it
like uh some guy because I posted on
Twitter for like a minute uh that I'm
talking to you and asking for questions
I I deleted that tweet because
you didn't 95 of the people were talk
about cheating talk about the cheating
all right I got it thank you this is not
going to be helpful at all so I was like
all right but in that time like there's
one comment which I'm it's hilarious to
me that you found that one comment the
one comment says like this seems like a
waste of time or something like why lame
guest lame guests
and then used like responded something
like with a question mark yeah yeah I
wrote wow my lame guests let's talk
about this yeah I was like why am I a
lame guest and he responded he responded
even after you deleted this that's what
he said he said he doesn't know what
value I would bring because I just make
videos about chess games yeah and that's
true you've had some absolutely
brilliant people on but I also looked at
this gentleman's profile and he his
he was one of the folks that put things
about his family and God and His
politics in his Twitter bio and I
started thinking
maybe I said something in some video and
I made a joke about
religion or something just some offhand
five second thing somewhere that someone
turns me into just an absolute outcast
in their household they can no longer
watch me and that has happened yeah that
has happened I'll record a 30 minute
video and I'll make a joke about
something and some phrasing and that's
it I've lost the viewer forever and they
will let me know they will write me an
email and I just don't think people
should be that serious
yeah there there's some of that because
I'll I've seen people say that sometimes
about me but I see it more with others
they'll say uh you know I used to be
like Joe Rogan gets this uh yeah I used
to be a huge fan of Joe Rogan until he
said this right it's like one
um first I do wonder if you were ever
really a big fan that's that's one
question mark I have but the other is
like I think when you should be more
lenient with each other
in terms of how much stupid [ __ ] we say
and and you know if you actually I wish
people were able to sort of introspect
on their own
on the OWN on the stupid [ __ ] they say
themselves like to have a little bit of
empathy like I wish there was a way to
read all the emails you've ever written
and just to see or maybe do a search
engine for all the stupid [ __ ] you've
said in emails in the past and like
summarize it and to reveal it to
yourself that like you have bad days you
have good days you have emotional days
uh you have stoic days you have
sometimes you have like uh you take very
different political views than you do on
other days and it's like it's all over
the place and if you're a Creator if
you're putting stuff out all the time
you're gonna have those and you're
you're still
you're still a full like complex bag of
emotions and thoughts and ideas and
contradictions and all that like you
shouldn't judge a person by a single
statement and even when you do you
should try to infer the best possible
interpretation of that statement I feel
like that
that's just a healthier way to interact
with the world than with other humans
it's like I wonder what's the best
possible
interpretation of the thing they just
tweeted or they said
like what let's let's imagine that the
person saying those words is actually a
really good human being and what do they
mean when they said
that thing about anal beads
so good for so long yeah right
uh or what whatever it is like you know
they didn't mean to be offensive
to the sexuality of a certain group
they're just talking about they're
talking [ __ ] about anal beads like
they're not uh like sometimes it's humor
sometimes it's actually genuinely
uh embodying like a political viewpoint
and like walking with it thinking
through it for a few days like
like taking it seriously empathizing not
just for a brief moment but for a time
like walking with an idea and allowing
yourself to express it like playing
doubles out I do that all the time with
yourself or with myself yeah in
conversation I do too and I find I have
to say I'm playing Devil's Advocate like
you have to be very explicit but with
myself I'll just do it
in my head like I have different voices
like you know uh obviously it just in
I've been getting so much information so
many thoughts
in all the complexities of the war in
Ukraine for example and all the
different voices within Ukraine I just
interviewed hundreds of people and they
have very different perspectives
in nuanced ways about the war some are
full of hate some are full of love like
hate for the other love for their own
country love for family and tradition
all of it it's a beautiful mix and I
have to walk
I have to like carry those ideas in my
head and empathize with them deeply and
then I have to listen to people that
live elsewhere that live in India they
have a very different perspective
there's a lot of people in India that
have a very different perspective the
people in Ukraine and so I don't know
and some of that will bleed out into the
thoughts I expressed publicly and um
like when people judge you harshly for
it it
first of all me as a human being is
psychologically difficult
uh but also it makes me less
willing to be fragile
I still try to be strong enough to be
fragile in front of the camera just say
like say things that are on my mind even
if I know it's going to
create uh
people that are going to be like
ruthlessly negative towards me so I
tried to wear my heart in my sleeve and
still try to be fragile but it's harder
you're going to pay a psychological cost
like like I'm you know in some sense I
try to be tough but like I could be a
softy in that in like
certain certain like attacks can get to
me so I'm surprised that they don't get
I mean do does some negativity get to
you
or is this the way you deal with it by
responding uh
like that that guy's saying like what
value does talking to let me add to the
world yeah no but that was I mean that
was so good I was looking at I was
thinking at various moments ever you
went to jump in and I was I was kind of
letting letting you speak one of the
things I wanted to mention was that
significantly simpler to talk about Chaz
than it is to talk about some of the
things you talk about and you have a big
responsibility because you have to
absorb information like a sponge
but you also then need to present it in
a way where you potentially have an
opinion while trying to be fair to
everybody and you're talking about
things that will literally never please
everybody just literally what else are
you going to talk about some issues that
are going to get out there into the
and people are going to watch it the
eyes right the years of of millions of
people and not everybody is going to be
satisfied and these are issues where
people are going to be much more likely
to speak up in all sorts of ways like a
tremendous support or tremendous hatred
vitriol and God knows what else yeah you
you it's one of the reasons I'm I'm
Blown Away to even be sitting here
frankly because up until a few months
ago you weren't talking to you know you
I'm not saying you weren't talking to
but you hadn't spoken to chess players
you were speaking to people who were
doing much more substantial things in
the world I appreciate the humility
there
just to me is incredible as a beautiful
game but I think the reason comments
hurt
is not I mean they hurt no matter what
to me like not to me because I'm in a
simpler space
that's what you have to understand it I
I even if so if it's chess based
criticism
it doesn't hit as hard no if you had a
podcast about
anal beads no I'm just I'm launching
this if you had a podcast watching a new
podcast photography you gotta you gotta
realize like it wouldn't it wouldn't be
the same way you talk about potentially
existential things you talk about uh
cyber you know things things in cyber
security or or AI or people who are
massive uh heads of companies that are
just inherently going to be a bit more
controversial so that I can't imagine
being in your shoes because you have so
many complex emotions about situations
where you may not necessarily agree with
everything that someone has said
publicly but you still invite them for a
conversation because they're a human
being it's totally different like I
don't know I not the way I experience it
to me I think what hurts
is it's not even on my because I'm super
self-critical usually way more than the
internet can be it's that like human
beings can be cruel to each other so
like the reason it hurts for some reason
is like this almost like this
disappointment in people they don't give
each other a chance so in that sense the
negativity doesn't have to be about
Ukraine or geopolitics it could be about
the silliest of things I said and like
to me it's like why why be mean to each
other in a context where the mean
doesn't
like it's out of place because I for
example there is like a gaming culture
where they just talk [ __ ] to each other
now stop
I think it's more
acceptable there it seems to fit it
seems to be funnier there in the like uh
when streamers talk [ __ ] to each other
I've been listening to several streamers
recently and it's like it somehow Works
a little better even if they're just
like cruel to each other it makes more
sense
um but I think what people are genuinely
trying to educate or to help and so on
and you still get the shitty comments I
don't know it makes me sad
no it doesn't it it doesn't make me
it doesn't make me sad I
think part of that is also the way I was
brought up so I was
I skipped kindergarten so I was always
the smallest kid
and you're picked on
I was picked on and then I did picking
so I had kind of both in my life I kind
of know I went home from summer camp
crying
and I also made a kid cry once in fourth
grade so I had the balance and a
physical or mental abuse or both verbal
verbal no I didn't beat anybody up I was
Tiny I think the kid in the younger
grade was bigger than I was and he still
broke them because that was an ass yeah
I so I had to use my mental Warfare I
had to use my words I had to be and
growing up I my parents blew when I was
super young and I played chess so all
things that make you super
self-trustworthy like you believe your
first instinct you don't listen to what
other people tell you and if people give
you advice say okay I'm gonna think
about that I'm not going to go in and do
that I wasn't impressionable you
couldn't convince me to do something
that stuck to this day my wife has had
to deconstruct some of my stubbornness I
didn't even realize was incredible
stubbornness it's just something that
you you brought up with so to me that
stuff doesn't bother me and it's it's so
the voices of others don't shake you
quite they can't mentally
um shake your like psychological
stability no they they haven't I I think
when it got probably at its worst point
was in combination with being unable to
perform well in over the board play but
that was also self-driven I wasn't
performing poorly because I was getting
comments
but because I was performing poorly the
comments got to me more
the cycle was sort of in the opposite
direction and that that was probably the
most frustrating out people have said
some vile things to me you know about my
whole Indonesia thing oh this is good
this is going to give the anarchist and
Lee chess all right let's go what's the
Indonesia yeah the way you said okay
maybe we don't want to talk about it no
no but let's let's talk no it's it's
it's totally fine I who did you kill I
didn't I I was gonna say I wish but I'm
not even sure I can make a joke like
that I
uh so the Indonesia thing was I was
streaming chess on chess.com I might add
uh and I got booted up a 10 minute game
just a random account from Indonesia
that was the flag now mind you on
these websites you can pick your flag
can be from wherever you don't it's not
geotracing you can change it I was like
okay I come from Indonesia and as always
I looked at the account because it was a
Untitled high rated account
and look through the games
win rate was suspiciously High average
accuracy was suspiciously High
okay I think this is a cheater I said it
out loud it's not the first time I
played cheaters on stream
and I saw cam still going to play Let's
see what happens
it was not crazy suspicious but
definitely suspicious a few critical
moments where I just clearly thought I
had a good position and then the person
or the bot played some move that just
killed my hopes and I lost
it's like okay I lost and uh I wrote to
the chess.com Fairplay team like behind
the scenes I wasn't even saying anything
publicly on stream and uh guy got banned
it was cheater
so that night
oh right before I'm going to sleep
because Indonesia is 12 hours ahead of
New York
go my Twitter
what the hell is going on I see hundreds
of responses to my recent tweets Levy
you gotta check Facebook man you gotta
check Facebook like so you got here's a
link
so
allegedly that account belonged to an
older gentleman
and his son made a Facebook post that
said
my dad played a big streamer in chess
Gotham chess and Gotham got mad he lost
to my dad so his community Mass reported
my dad and he was banned for cheating
oh it went viral oh no did you know that
in Indonesia has the fourth largest
population
in the world I didn't know I learned it
the hard way interesting tens of
thousands of DMS every second Wow
Instagram DMS because I had my DMs open
I was never afraid of that stuff uh my
YouTube videos went from 99 of uh I'll
vote down vote
50 50. oh wow they swarmed myself all
negative oh no all play him again you I
I mean I don't know how much swearing
there is on this podcast but I mean it
was just all sorts of all the [ __ ]
swearing uh they
just everything ruthless The Vicious
they were gonna kill me they were going
to rape my family they were going to
they were contacting people I followed
on Instagram they were contacting them
and telling them crazy things it was I'm
not joking it was tens of thousands of
people every minute it was unbelievable
and I didn't know what to do because the
guy cheated I was in the right yeah
people how certain were you that he
cheated 100 okay 100 I'm okay I don't
know if you can say 100 but suggest.com
had also had a suspicion hey why does
they have like good they have the good
detection algorithms yes Danny wrench
would be able to I legitimately know
nothing about the behind the scenes
because it's only kind of tech people
but uh what one thing I did not realize
was that this account whether it was the
sun playing or the father playing we
will not know we don't know who played
it could have been the sun it could have
been the dad covering for him whatever
but
at some point that account won 27 games
in a row at 95 accuracy I mean even
Magnus can't do that even
you know uh this took a month this story
took one month from start to finish
first I had to work with a like a media
company to Geo block my content in
Indonesia on YouTube so Indonesians
could not see my channel oh so you you
didn't want to like lean into it Go full
Donald Trump no no let's let's uh
because you're in the right you feel
like you're in the right you as far as
you know you're in the right yeah and I
hated watching all my work burn to the
ground like oh you felt it was being
yeah and I'm one thing I'm learning
about myself is I'm not a good crisis
actor I need someone to like slap me so
I don't do something emotional in the
moment when crisis is ongoing what would
be the emotional act that's not
productive there
partnering with an MCN that makes you
give away a bunch of your revenue and
then when you break with them I wasn't
monetized for a week it was a very big
decision to plug in I think they're
called mcns but what are they sorry I
don't know they're like we there's
they're specialized agencies that work
behind the scenes with YouTube yeah that
if you connect your account they say
they can give you certain ad benefits
they can Geo block your content they
which you can't do normally they have
certain perks that only YouTube allows
behind the scenes you pay them 10 of
your monthly ad Revenue but they claim
to do a handful of things for you I just
needed them to geoblock my content I I
just didn't I didn't care how much money
I was uh going to give away per month
but so why geo block it you just didn't
like the the downboarding
yeah I didn't want you wanted positivity
more like you're being educational
you're I mean they're like you do a bit
of [ __ ] talking but it's more like fun
and easy going you didn't want this kind
of viciousness yeah my comment section
was just being completely flooded like
they were destroying my channel and to
be honest maybe all of the views and the
downvotes out of would have actually
been beneficial maybe I mean my videos
would have actually started getting
recommended to more people yeah but I'm
a person this is Hill goes back to the
same oh so this got to you yeah this was
like I was just watching it and I'm like
this is not fair this is I don't I don't
know what to do so I'm gonna stop this
as much as I can they still got through
they have VPN and they were like you
[ __ ] you don't think we have VPN in
Indonesia it was this whole you know it
was this whole thing
um
this father and son got invited to every
major News Network I'm not joking they
got invited to the major podcast they
like to say The Joe Rogan of Indonesia
yeah Daddy corbosier is this Mentalist
he's a bald guy very fun guy he had them
and that's when the Indonesian Chess
Federation stepped in the thing is
nobody who was harassing me knows
anything about Chess they just saw the
story
and a long story short they brought in a
sponsor the guy played a strong uh one
of the strongest chess players in the
country who also happens to be a woman
Irene sukhandar she's like 2400
International Master she crushed him
because his actual playing strength is
thirteen hundred fourteen hundred you
something like that he still got paid
because there was a winning price point
a losing price fund and we never heard
from him again
and that was the whole search that was
that was why I had to shut down all of
my social media to DMS and DM requests
and even notifications like I don't get
notifications unless it's someone I
follow but see stuff like that doesn't
often get resolved in this kind of clear
way no it doesn't it could have been so
you got lucky there that there's um a
conclusion to this yeah somebody got
views somebody got money
uh and
I never got I never got many apologies
what did you learn from that experience
about yourself about about the internet
I think first and foremost I learned
that
every moment
you are live or broadcasting can be
completely blown out of proportion you
have to be real careful and
I can't actively think about that
unfortunately even when I'm streaming
I've had other instances
where things come back to bite I've even
had these moments live on stream I feel
like I said something too sarcastically
to somebody and I don't know how their
day is going in my ruin their whole day
you know God God knows what you have
these moments of regret where you want
your personality to shine through and
you want to entertain
at least you're thinking at what cost
if I make a joke to a viewer that
suddenly the whole chat is laughing at
them
what if that puts them in a deep dark
place and again so it all comes back to
this one-on-one thing for me because I'm
a human I would hate to put another
person into that situation if I would
much rather get a drink with somebody
than then but it's all kind of part of
this act and you want to make jokes and
I also learned I'm a horrible crisis
actor so I have no patience but I think
that's normal in 2022 everything is
immediate we can barely sit
think let time go by
it makes me sad because I think that
kind of stuff can destroy good people
that's what makes you sad yeah well one
of the things we discussed just here
before recording which I'm also I've
talked about this on stream I'm very
open with this type of stuff is over the
I think for me a lot of that comes down
to just a lack of control of the of the
narrative that's that phrase is kind of
messy it can be used for political stuff
but I I hate when I say things and they
get completely misconstrued or they
are completely misinterpreted and I
can't imagine being in your shoes
because again I do chess you cannot
really you can clip me
saying something about a chess game out
of context and it's hilarious you know
it's it's dumb it's it's nothing
it's not an attack on on me or or
something that I said it's not an attack
on
kind of more more similarly to to what
you were describing uh and you know you
don't say you don't say stuff like that
like ridiculous you don't say ridiculous
[ __ ] about yourself oh I do that I do I
do and you don't feel like that could be
made isn't this the same guy that said X
maybe maybe I I either haven't said
enough of those things or there's no
moments in I don't have three four hour
open conversations with other humans and
I'm pretty sure if I did there would be
more of that that stuff out there but uh
that's probably what it is just the lack
of
it's a lack of being able to kind of
control what is actually reality and and
that that is very frustrating and uh
yeah you're right I mean there is a
sense that there's not enough motivation
for people to attack you you're
ultimately adding a lot of positive
stuff to the world and when you get into
more political topics there's people
there who are hurting who have a lot of
anger in their hearts and they want to
direct it towards you so then they need
ammunition and ammunition comes in the
way of like clips from the past so I'm
sure that you I'm pretty sure you
already have Clips like that it's just
there's not people that really have
anger to direct towards you ultimately
you're adding a lot of good stuff to the
world and so yeah but it's man the
the viciousness of human beings
under the veil of anonymity at scale can
be really painful so that that's I guess
that's the curse the challenge of being
a Creator on YouTube and so on on Twitch